One factory has machines that produce toys,
which are then packed by factory workers.
One day each machine produced 14 toys,
and every worker packed two toys,
so a total of 40 toys remained unpackaged.
In addition, the number of workers on that day was 8 less
of 7 by the number of machines.
How many machines and workers did they have there?
I recommend that you pause the video.
This is a nice little task here.
Okay, let's define some variables.
Let M say that M is equal
of the number of machines
and that W equals
of the number of workers.
These labels look good for the variables.
What does the first sentence say to us?
It tells us that each machine produced 14 toys this day.
Once every machine has produced 14 toys,
what is the total number of toys,
which were produced?
The total number of toys that have been
produced will be the number of toys per machine
by number of machines.
These are 14M produced toys.
They were so produced.
How many toys were packed?
Once every worker has packed two toys,
we are told that each worker has packed two toys,
so that the total number that was packaged,
is 2 toys per worker per worker.
This is the number of packed toys.
We also know the number of toys that remain,
the total number of unpackaged toys.
It is told that they are 40.
Let me write it in neutral color.
40, we can look at it
40 as produced,
but unpackaged.
This is the total number of those left unpackaged.
Okay, how will we link the produced and packaged
with those that are not packaged?
If we take the total number produced
and take out the number that was packed,
we will have the total number of unpackaged.
So we succeeded
to create a linear relationship between M and W.
Only one equation is not enough to find M and W,
but we also have another dependency.
It is also told us that the number of workers
on that day,
let's say W, I'll write it here.
W, the number of workers this day,
was 8 less than 7 on the number of machines.
Or you can say he was equal to 7 in number
machines minus 8.
This will be 8 less than 7 in number
of machines.
7M minus 8.
We now have two equations with two unknowns.
If things are fine, we can succeed
to find W and M.
There are many ways to do it.
Since this equation has already been decided for W,
here we can make a substitution.
We can take this W and substitute it for this W.
In fact, I should say, we can take 7M minus 8
and substitute it for this W,
because M and W, the couple we want to find,
must satisfy both equations.
That's what we'll get
14M
minus 2,
on ...
And instead of W
I can write
7M minus 8
and we get that
is equal to 40.
Now a little algebra.
14M and then, let's see ...
Now I will write everything in neutral color.
Minus 2 at 7M
is minus 14M
and then minus 2 by minus 8
is plus 16,
and then it will be 40.
14M minus 14M will be just 0
and we stay with 16 is equal to 40.
But that will never be true.
16 will never be equal to 40.
No matter what M and W are.
Even if M and W are eliminated from this equation,
such a thing is impossible.
It is impossible
16 to be equal to 40
and therefore there are no solutions.
There is no pair M and W,
which meets the conditions given to us,
so there is no solution.
No solution.
I will surround it in a small box.